en gas de l'illa en las afueras de
bagdad el responsable de la distribución
de combustible en estas calles no tiene
más de 10 años sin embargo intenta
hacerse respetar
este niño iraquí tuvo que dejar sus
estudios y trabajar para conseguir algo
de dinero para su madre desempleada
un poco más allá su competencia uno de
ellos no tiene más de seis años
todos estos niños vienen de un barrio
marginal conocido como 'la carilla la
aldea en árabe
y hoy sus habitantes esperan al que
llaman papá noel
henri que es un funcionario iraquí que
pasa gran parte de su tiempo libre aquí
hay adaptado para vivir
ayuda a estas familias con un poco de
dinero para disuadirlas de enviar a sus
hijos a la calle
[Música]
y tengan 6 o 13 años todos estos niños
trabajan para intentar salir de la
pobreza
henrik no los culpa pero le preocupa que
estos pequeños trabajos puedan llegar a
ser peligrosos en irak
hay niños que trabajan para llevarles
dinero a sus padres pero también están
los que trabajan para mafias redes
con gente de poder a veces contratan a
niñas de 6 7 8 9 años
hacen trabajos esporádicos y luego
cuando tienen 14 o 15 se dedican a la
prostitución
los padres conocen los riesgos pero
dicen no tener otra opción esta madre
perdió a su esposo hace dos años en esta
sociedad conservadora es el hombre quien
suele mantener a la familia por lo que
decidió retirar a sus hijos pequeños de
la escuela desde entonces uno de ellos
recoge latas en la calle para vender el
acero el otro día se lastimó se cortó la
mano con el acero tuve que llevarlo al
hospital para que le pusieran ventosa sé
que quiere volver a la escuela pero ni
siquiera tengo dinero para comprarle
ropa pantalones libros que puedo hacer
estoy sola
más de un millón de niños ya trabajaban
en irak antes de la pandemia con la
crisis sanitaria y económica ahora son
aún más
en bagdad la brigada de menores se
encarga de frenar el fenómeno
el general adnan hamad es uno de sus
comandantes
la policía de menores debe rondar por la
noche en lugares sospechosos como cafés
bares y cines y buscar a los jóvenes
delincuentes detenerlos y entregarlos a
sus familias a cambio de un compromiso
personal adiós a cesc sin embargo estas
operaciones son limitadas la brigada
está compuesta por sólo 350 hombres y
carece gravemente de recursos según este
general
el trabajo infantil es un problema
importante pero por ejemplo no tenemos
suficientes refugios para albergarlos
desde los años 80 el ministerio de
trabajo no construye uno así que hay que
hacer algo y eso resulta alarmante
porque en todo irak sólo hay un centro
de acogida gubernamental para niños sin
familia su directora qaida accedió a
abrirnos las puertas de este refugio
oficialmente sólo se pueden acoger 75
niños aquí por aquí estamos
sobrecargados tenemos alrededor de 93
niños aquí hoy donde pueda ubicar luego
que poner colchones en el piso y hacer
que tu hermana ya
la escuela del refugio está cerrada
desde el comienzo de la pandemia pero
algunas actividades como esta clase de
música se mantienen de forma ocasional
algo para hacer sonreír a los niños
porque muchos de ellos sufren traumas
psicológicos
algunos de ellos cayeron en la
delincuencia como este joven de 16 años
que acaba de salir de la cárcel tras
pasar 24 meses en prisión
en la cárcel éramos muchos quizás 65
menores en una habitación un poco más
grande que ésta sólo había una puerta
cerrada con un pequeño agujero en el
centro y nos golpeaban allá y no
podíamos hablar libremente no hay
comparación me siento bien acá junto a
marta es vicky cuando alcanzan la
mayoría de edad estos jóvenes tienen que
ir se acaban de nuevo en la calle sin
apoyo ni seguimiento por parte de las
autoridades esta falta de estrategia
global abruma a gajda y a los demás
actores de la lucha contra el trabajo
infantil mientras las autoridades no
hagan de esto una prioridad el trabajo
infantil seguirá existiendo en irak